people like invention but the problem is
they don't like failure and you cannot
have invention without failure
i want to make sure tesla recruiting
does not have anything that says
requires
university because that's absurd this
moment in time
this is your time to rise
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
i believe hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best
believe life and learn the seven best
lessons from elon musk warren buffett
jeff bezos and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn from trial and error with jeff
bezos failure and invention are
inseparable twins
um you know it's everybody wants to
be inventive you know if you go talk to
corporate america or
uh any any institution actually uh
government agencies and so on
innovation is something to be proud of
people like invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure
if you
[Music]
to know where if you already know it's
going to work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real
invention the most important inventions
come
from trial and error with lots of
failure and and the failure is critical
um and it's also embarrassing and so
that's why
people and when we're kids
we always are doing trial and error and
we're never embarrassed you know if you
watch a little toddler
and they will try for hours to put a
square peg in a round hole
and it never works but it doesn't keep
them from trying
and they try things like that and that's
how they learn
and uh and and we all have that when
we're little and then as we get older
somehow it's not as cool as you get
older to fail and to fall down it looks
clumsy
and so we get in our grooves we have a
set of expertise and skills it's kind of
a comfort zone
and you have to constantly push yourself
to say no
i don't care about failure in fact if
you know i said amazon
we have to grow the size of our failures
as the size of our company grows we have
to make bigger and bigger failures
because otherwise none of our failures
will be needle movers
and so i would see it as a very bad sign
over the long run
if amazon wasn't making larger and
larger failures
and if you do that all along the way
that is going to protect you from ever
having to make
that big you know kind of hail mary bet
that you sometimes
see companies make right before they
fail and go out of existence rule number
two
rise with oprah winfrey you can use your
gifts that's what you're really here to
do
to illuminate the darkness in our world
so this is what i also know that this
this this moment in time
this is your time to rise
it is even though
you can't go anywhere you can't stand in
line at starbucks you can't go to a
party
you can't go to any place without
everywhere you turn
people are talking about how bad things
are how terrible it is
and this is what i know the problem is
everybody is meeting hysteria with more
hysteria
and then we just are all becoming
hysterical and it's getting worse
what i've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to
match it or even get locked into
resisting
or pushing against it we're supposed to
see
this moment in time for what it is
we're supposed to see through it and
then transcend it
that is how you overcome hysteria
and that is how you overcome the sniping
at one another
the trolling the mean-spirited
partisanship on
both sides of the aisle the divisiveness
the injustices
and the out and out hatred
you use it use this moment
to encourage you to embolden you and to
literally push you into the rising
of your life and to borrow a phrase from
my
beloved mentor maya angelou just like
moons
and like sons with the certainty of
tides
just like the hopes springing high you
will rise rule number three do something
exceptional with elon musk
well we have a lot of good good people
at spacex that
a lot of really talented people uh
in fact i wonder like sometimes how we
can make use of their talents
in the best way because you know i think
we're often
not using their talents in the best way
um
yeah but you know to the point of the
question i was just asked i want to make
sure
tesla recruiting does not have anything
that says requires
university because that's absurd
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability i don't
consider going to college
evidence of exceptional ability in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know you look at
like
you know gates is a pretty smart guy he
dropped out
john was pretty smart he dropped out you
know larry ellison
smart guy he dropped out i'm like
obviously not needed
so did shakespeare even go to college
probably not
also if you want to have more
self-belief and self-confidence i've
designed a special free program
to help you get it where i send you a
video every day
for 254 days the research says it can
take up to 254 days for you to build a
new habit and this program will help you
get it once again it's free and the link
to join is in the description below
if you're doing anything interesting in
the world you're gonna have critics
the only way if you absolutely can't
tolerate critics then don't do anything
new
or interesting the way through the
challenge
is to get still and ask yourself what is
the next
right move investing in yourself is the
best thing you can do anything that
improves your own talent like nobody can
take it away from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
become worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
rule number four be a problem solver
with jack ma
when i started alibaba 1999
i want to share some of things first we
believe in the future
and i believe internet can empower our
people it's not
jack ma helped so many people
it's the entrepreneurships the spirit
of creating the spirit
of constructive advice and disease
and very also very very important
is that we believe technology will help
people
for a better future so
we try to be creative we try to solve
problems
when people complain we don't complain
we think about complaining of the other
people is always a great opportunity
if we can solve the complaining and then
we have the solutions
then we have the future so we do alibaba
because we believe in there are so many
small businesses don't know
when and how where they can sell the
products so we help them to promote
their products
we have the payment because no banks at
that time
love to help small business and they
don't know how to help a small business
we know if we don't have a payment our
e-commerce is just a talk
on the line it's just the chat online
so we have this payment and then we find
if we cannot help people to deliver
efficiently and quickly
then there will be no way so we build up
the
the uh the logistics system and then we
find a lot of companies don't
have the technology especially small
business they don't know how to use the
internet
the internet service is too expensive
then so we say all right let's build up
the cloud computing
so every small business can using cloud
computing
internet technology cheaply and
efficiently so it's all about solving
problems
so i think this is what we did
in the past 20 years we always think
about
what we can do to solve this social
problems
instead of complaining that's that's the
journey
and i'm having great fun when you really
help people when you see
millions of people change their lives
because
the efforts that we work together rule
number five
learn the principles with warren buffett
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean
that doesn't mean that industries stay
good forever or businesses stay good
forever but
but learning to think about business
models what i learned at 20 is useful to
me now what i learned at 25 is useful to
me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes dramatically in terms of the
underlying principles it's like physics
i mean there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager
you know if he knows what makes a a good
product
uh and you learn that in one business
you can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and uh i don't think i can win every
game
you know somebody said how do you beat
bobby fischer you play him any game
except chess
so i don't play bobby fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at
rule number six aim to be the best with
mark zuckerberg
the first set of schools that we
launched after harvard were schools that
had other kind of school specific social
networks so i think it was
stanford had something um colombia had
something
and i think yale had something so i
think why did you choose ones that had
school specific social networks because
i wanted to competitors
well i wanted to go to the schools that
i thought would be the hardest for us to
succeed at because i knew that if we had
a product that was better than
everything else that other students were
making at other colleges then it would
be worth investing in and putting and
putting time into but i didn't want to
just kind of
like get into a project where there
would end up being this huge legacy of
maintaining it if
ultimately there were just going to be
different things that were as good as it
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is take calculated risks with sarah
blakely
being an entrepreneur is about taking
risks but it's about taking very
calculated risks
and being you know protecting the
downside so i didn't quit my job selling
fax machines
until i had already invented the product
i was working on it at night and on the
weekends for two years
i was driving around north carolina
where most hosiery was made begging a
bunch of manufacturing plants to help
make it
and i didn't quit my job until i had
already landed neiman marcus saks fifth
avenue and got a call from oprah
just a typical day then i was like okay
i feel confident to quit but i needed
the income that was coming in and i
needed my health care benefits and i
was working out of my apartment in
virginia highlands
and i ran spanx out of my apartment for
two and a half years and it was crazy i
mean i'd semi trucks pulling up
twice a week to this apartment and my
neighbors were like what's happening
what's going on
but i was so conservative with my
finances
in the beginning i was very scrappy and
still am really scrappy
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and how are you going to take action on
it this week when you schedule in what
day what time and what place you're
going to take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan and when
you share your plan publicly and have
some accountability you increase your
chances even further of
actually following through so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
if you take a look at life you can have
your glasses they say half empty or half
full is how you look at it
now i've been homeless twice when you
are down
first time was 22 years old and i had a
child
homeless with a kid you know he was a
couple years old which would be
interesting because most people see you
now in this multi-billion dollar
situation
they would never believe that at 22. you
were homeless with a kid
i mean it didn't look like the
trajectory was heading here right yep
yeah
but when you're down and out and you're
that far down and you've got a kid
and you're kicked out of your place
because rents do you don't have the
money and your wife took off with
everything
everything yeah just little kids wow
anyways we were just too young to get
married
uh so you know how to make it now when
you're that low
found a friend of mine who's a blue
singer said when you get down so low and
you look up all you can see is an edge
right
when you're that low you could only go
up so instead of you have a choice
you could sit around and blame what
happened to you on
everybody else which is usually what
people do
or say hey that's how things turned out
now i'm going to turn things around
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
seven
more awesome lessons from billionaire
entrepreneurs check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there